- TONIGHT, MOONBEAM CITY
IS UNDER SIEGE
AT THE HANDS OF A PETTY THUG
TURNED WARLORD.
IN JUST A SINGLE NIGHT,
HE TURNED $42 OF PURSE MONEY
INTO A VERITABLE EMPIRE
OF DRUG TRAFFICKING,
ARMS DEALING,
AND INFANT NEGLECTING.
THE MADMAN ANSWERS TO THE NAME
EL DIABLO MALO.
TRANSLATION:
THE BAD DEVIL.
A NICKNAME AS UNCREATIVE
AS IT IS TERRIFYING.
- ARE YOU PLEASED WITH YOURSELF?
- NO MORE THAN USUAL.
- SURE, YOU ONLY LET
ONE MEASLY GUY GET AWAY,
AND NOW HE'S RUNNING
THE GODDAMN CITY.
- NOT THE WHOLE CITY,
JUST UPPER MIDTOWN
AND LOWER DOWNTOWN
AND MIDDLE UPTOWN LOWTOWN.
BESIDES,
IT'S MOSTLY POOR PEOPLE.
- WHERE EXACTLY DID YOU
END UP LAST NIGHT?
- I WAS PURSUING
SOME HOT LEADS.
LEGALLY, I CAN MAKE ANY
THREE PEOPLE HERE DO EACH OTHER.
TAKE IT.
SHOW YOUR FRIENDS.
WHO WANTS SOME?
[slurps loudly]
- HOW LONG IS THIS
GOING TO LAST?
- AS LONG AS HEARTLESS CROOKS
HAVE SNAKES FOR HEARTS.
- NO, THIS.
- I PAID FOR 48 HOURS.
- GET YOUR SKANKS
OUT OF MY OFFICE.
- HEY, THEY HAVE NAMES,
PROBABLY.
[whispering]
KEEP DANCING.
I'LL MEET YOU
IN THE MEN'S ROOM IN FIVE.
- DAZZLE, I NEED YOU
TO FOCUS,
AND I'M GONNA HELP YOU
BY TAKING AWAY
SOME DISTRACTIONS.
FOR STARTERS...
YOUR GUN.
- WHAT?
THEN ALL I'LL HAVE
ARE THESE WORTHLESS KNIVES.
- AND I'M DISMANTLING
YOUR NAP NOOK.
- SO I'M SUPPOSED TO NAP
ON MY COUCH LIKE A DOG?
- OH, AND I HOPE
YOU'RE NOT TOO ATTACHED TO THIS.
- NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO.
HOW ELSE WILL PEOPLE KNOW
THAT I'M THE NUMBER ONE COP?
I CAN'T DRINK OUT OF A TROPHY.
I'LL LOOK LIKE AN IDIOT.
- I'LL TELL YOU HOW.
GO OUT
AND CAPTURE THAT PSYCHOPATH.
I'M GIVING YOU
FIVE DAYS, DAZZLE,
OR YOU'LL BE GONE SO FAST,
YOUR HEAD'LL SPIN.
- MY HEAD DOESN'T KNOW
THE MEANING OF THE WORD SPIN.
[slurps and exhales sharply]
THIS IS HUMILIATING.
- YOU'RE TELLING ME,
BROTHER.
- IT TASTES LIKE DEATH.
- REALLY?
BECAUSE I DRINK
FROM THE CUP OF LIFE.
- RAD CUNNINGHAM,
KING DICK
OF THE ASS FOREST.
- I SEE YOU'VE MET
MY SPECIAL LADY.
I'VE BEEN USING HER
FOR ALL KINDS OF THINGS:
SPITTING TOBACCO,
GIVING BATHS TO MY MICE,
STORING MY FARTS.
- YOU MONSTER.
SHE WASN'T MADE FOR MOUSE BATHS.
SHE'S AN ANGEL.
- WELL, SHE'S MINE NOW, OKAY?
JUST LIKE YOUR OFFICE
WILL BE
AND YOUR CRYSTAL HOUSE DOME
ON THE MOONBEAM BAY.
DON'T LIKE IT?
SHOOT ME.
- I WANT TO,
BUT I CAN'T.
- [laughing]
[door knob clicking]
GOT IT.
[laughs]
[door clanks open]